Знамениті берлінські вечірки тепер вже точно закінчилися
Клуби й паби зачинилися, а коли молодь продовжила збиратися у парках
для так званих "коронавечірок", один власник супермаркету застеріг у "Фейсбуку":
він не продаватиме їм алкоголь та наїдки.
Навіть послідовникам Грети Тунберг
знадобилося дещо більше часу,
аби зрозуміти, наскільки серйозною є ця ситуація.
Тож, вечірок у Берліні вже немає.
І все ж, коли я виходжу на пробіжку,
саме молоді люди найчастіше не дотримуються правила:
"Зберігай дистанцію у півтора метри".
У поліції мне сказали, що в них не було особливих проблем
з дотриманням людьми засобів суворої ізоляції - навіть серед підлітків.
Причому ці заходи - одні з найсуворіших у світі.
В Іспанії вже не дозволяють навіть виходити на прогулянку.
Тут, у Франції, багато молодих людей спочатку, здавалося,
не сприймали ізоляцію всерйоз, одна група навіть влаштувала барбекю
на півночі Франції та мусила сплатити
штраф у розмірі 1600 євро.
Але часи, схоже, змінилися.
Молоді люди тепер організовуються онлайн,
і одна група Facebook, яка налічує понад шістсот тисяч людей,
навіть влаштовує 10-хвилинну онлайнвечірку щодня.
Однак молодь піклується не лише про власні розваги.
Є веб-сайт, який знайомить людей, які працюють у таких лікарнях, як оця,
з тими, хто хоче допомогти їм у догляді за дІтьми або купівлею продуктів.
І переважна більшість з майже сімдесяти тисяч волонтерів -
це підлітки й 20-річні.
Школи у Великобританії - як дорогі приватні школи,
так і звичайні державні - проводять онлайнкласи.
Особисто у моєму випадку це означає, що тепер у мене вдома
три підлітки, які продовжують старанно вчитися.
Щоправда, це не обходиться без певних проблем.
. Один з моїх синів сказав мені нещодавно:
Мамо, я ніколи не думав, що скажу це, але - я сумую за школою.
Тут, у США, одна з найбільших проблем для уряду полягає в тому,
щоб переконати американців ставитися до коронавірусу серйозно.
Попри наявність не менше 15 розпоряджень про те, щоб залишатися вдома,
у парках і на вулицях, як і раніше, багато людей.
Особливо у соціальних мережах відчувається розрив між поколіннями -
часто саме молодь виявляє мало співчуття до літніх людей,
які перебувають у групі ризику.
Як і більшість людей у цілому світі, південнокорейці
реагували на цю пандемію по-різному.
Тиждень тому на вихідні багато молодих людей прийшли сюди у Хонг Дай -
важальний і торговельний район у Сеулі,
популярний серед молоді.
Їх різко розкритикували в інтернеті за те,
що вони збиралися в нічних клубах та барах.
Інші молоді люди, з якими я зустрічався,
на волонтерських засадах допомагали роздавати їжу нужденним та виготовляти маски.
Поліція Брюсселя активізувала свої зусилля,
аби не допустити зустрічей у парках,
особливо груп молоді.
Нещодавнє дослідження показало, що 44 відсотки,
майже половина, з 18-20-річних
не дотримувалися правил соціальної дистанції.
Але є й позитивні новини.
Близько 600 людей, серед яких багато студентів,
записалися у список добровольців, які допомагають лікарням
та будинкам для людей похилого віку.
Приблизно п'ятнадцять закладів звернулися за такою допомогою
і тепер з нетерпінням очікують її від студентів та нещодавніх випускників.
Я перебуваю в нетрях Кібери, де, власне, ці молоді чоловіки й жінки
ведуть боротьбу з поширенням коронавірусу.
Ці станції для миття рук контролюються молодими людьми,
які пропонують усім охочим уроки гігієни, а також закликають
зберігати соціальну дистанцію, хоча це тут одне з найскладніших завдань.
Тут, у Колумбії, багато молодих людей
використовують вільний час для надання допомоги нужденним.
У великих містах країни з'являються приватні ініціативи,
які закликають молодих та здорових людей
ходити за покупками для літніх людей.
Багато з них волонтери, вони намагаються
убезпечити найбільші групи ризику, приносячи їм продукти, ліки,
засоби особистої гігієни до дверей, уникаючи особистого контакту.
Це дозволяє найбільш уразливими категоріям населення
населення залишатися вдома й відчувати себе менш безпомічними в ці часи.
Молодь особливо перейшла в онлайн-простір як для роботи, так і для відпочинку.
Крім того, учні деяких приватних шкіл також намагаються продовжувати
вчитися за допомогою додатків та онлайн-платформ.
Є й ті, хто допомагає іншим у цей кризовий час.
Оскільки під час суворої ізоляції пересування обмежене,
в деяких місцевих громадах молоді люди використовують соцмережі,
аби координувати свої зусилля й забезпечувати літнім людям
доставку предметів першої необхідності.
Поки уряд ухвалює рішучі заходи зі стримування поширення коронавірусу,
молоді люди знаходять більш творчі шляхи,
аби поліпшити поінформованість та побороти дезінформацію -
наприклад, за допомогою навчальних відеороликів місцевими мовами,
а також комедійних пародій у соцмережах.